let's just get a little bit more about
that breaking news in the channel and
joined by the Kent MP Damian green
screen it's always love to see you but
on occasion like this dear goodness how
much more do you know I suspect you
might know a little bit no I know I know
no more than is is coming out uh
publicly but it's it's clearly Grim
incredibly Grim just describe what it
will be like in the channel at this time
of year I think we can all pretty much
guess though yeah I mean it's it's
freezing cold
um there's not much wind so I can you
know you can see that these terrible
criminal gangs who organize this uh will
have pushed boats out uh from France but
but yeah I mean you just fear that the
chance of anyone in the water surviving
very long we saw that terrible tragedy
in solihull that was in a lake you know
imagine what the channels like
just this the scale of the rescue effort
and of course we have had small boats
you know capsizing in the channel on
occasions before it is the scale of the
rescue effort on this one that that left
out to me I wonder whether it should
we've got we've got light votes for a
number of stations we have UK Navy boat
we have a French French navy boat we
have air abstraction rescue two
helicopters a near ambula and so on
scene I mean is that the kind of level
of response that you get at times like
this or does that suggest something well
I mean it suggests how serious it is but
that's obvious anyway but but yes there
are you know because of what what's
happening uh then both our Navy and and
the French navy and obviously border
Force and and lifeboats are very very
aware of the possibility of this
happening we saw it once before it was
just over a year ago since we had the
the previous big tragedy and and you
just have to draw the conclusion that
you know we need to stop this not just
because we won't of our board is
important though that is but to save
lives that this is not in any way a safe
decent way for people to get to this
country it it certainly isn't but there
are thousands that have done and and
will continue to do so the only way to
stop people dying in the channel is to
stop people presumably getting in
getting into those boats and in the
first place is is there nothing I mean
of course we were hearing from Richie
tonight yesterday about getting people
back to Albania uh quickly if they're
not supposed to be here of course for
that to have happened they need to have
crossed the channel do we not now need
to think even more seriously about
something on the French beaches I know
we've increased the amount of money that
we're paying and we know we have police
officers there but as yet that doesn't
seem to have had an effect it's it's had
some effect but not much yeah I agree
but but yes we need to act on the French
beaches but also we need to act further
Upstream if you like we know that a
third of the people trying to cross the
channel are from Albania uh Albania is a
safe country it's a NATO Ally of ours
it's a a accession country it's trying
to join the European Union
um and it's a democracy so there is no
reason for anyone to be a refugee from
Albania and one of the things that was
announced yesterday they didn't attract
much attention was that we're not going
to have border Force officers at Tirana
so that will stop people leaving in the
first place and the other thing of
course is that if if it becomes
recognized that actually Britain has got
tougher and it is returning people more
and faster than it has before then that
itself will act to determine we'll have
fewer people in this dangerous position
yeah and and of course all of these
measures incrementally will have an
effect and we will need to to let them
run for a while to see to see the full
effect but I am just healing in my year
but according to French sources
between 30 and 50 people were apparently
on this boat that is that is the scale
of the of the rescue operation that is
ongoing right now as a Kent MP you will
know you will have spent time with the
rnli and and search and rescue they have
an awful lot of experience at dealing
with the weather conditions that are
around right now I suspect yeah I mean
the rnli is a voluntary organization the
people doing it are volunteers it is one
of the most magnificent Charities we
have in this country it's people putting
their own lives at risk to save other
people's lives and they will be doing
their their absolute best to try and get
people if they're in the water out of
the water fast enough so that they've
survived it's um if there were that many
people and if the boat is capsized then
again you know the only word I can use
is grim and it's a desperate situation
yeah I just want one last question if I
can just on the kind of the
practicalities of of the way that people
are applying for Asylum here at the
moment look if if you don't come from
Afghanistan Ukraine or Hong Kong at the
moment there is precious little way that
you can get to the United Kingdom to
apply for Asylum until that changes it
strikes me that we are likely to see
people still attempting that route
across the channel as the only way that
they can get here you couldn't get in
through an airport you might get in
um on the coast is there not an emerging
argument for us to have some form of
Border force on the beaches in in Cali
to process people there or until we
start the process so that we don't have
to risk now potentially 30 to 50 people
losing their lives this morning I I I I
I'm not trying to be a motive about this
but no no I I get the point and and I
think whatever argument knows for that
there's probably a better argument for
saying to do it around the world to
designate places where you can come as a
refugee as we have done I'm not just the
places you mentioned but Syria as well
there was a successful Syrian scheme
where we take people from from camps in
in the area where they get displaced I
think it's it's more important to do
that because as you say once they've got
to the beaches in northern France then
they spent all the money they've been in
the hands of criminal gangs for a long
time it would be much better to do it at
source in an area where where the
British people will be generous to
people who are genuinely fear fleeing
war and persecution they just don't like
being sort of Taken for a ride by people
who are using our instinctive generosity
towards genuine refugees to exploit the
system and we've got we've got to sort
of break that link and the details kind
of still emerging through my year at the
moment um local sources telling us the
search operation will continue through
the day there is a certainty that there
have been fatalities and indeed given
the temperature of the water right now
this is this is not a search and rescue
operation this is a certain Discovery
operation I mean just just a final
thought from you about
the the way in which so many lives have
essentially been been lost at a time
like this and I mean it is grim in
anyone's world but but this is happening
again and again and again and and
something needs to be done doesn't it
yeah absolutely and and yeah yeah one of
the effects hopefully of yesterday's
announcement
um is that we minimize the number of
people trying to use this this desperate
unsafe potentially fatal route to get to
this country uh and you know the fewer
people try it the better it is for them
as as well as for us
um demon green we will leave it there
thank you so much for your time this
morning